what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down and explaining every
captain's power from bleach we have a
lot of captains to break down today as
we will not only be looking at the
current captains but the former ones too
now if you do enjoy these bleach videos
on the channel and you'd like to see
more you know what to do smash that like
button get sugar 10 show style if you
haven't already make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications you
can also follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar and now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all
the 13 court guard squads or the goti 13
are the military and protectors of the
soul society they are responsible for
the defense of the serete the deployment
of division members and task forces as
well as guiding souls to the soul
society genre yusai yamamoto was the
founder of the gotai 13 and was the head
of the organization now a lot of the
early history is unknown but we do know
that the first generation of captains
included of course yamamoto himself una
hana and 11 others shun sui the current
captain of squad 1 considered that first
generation of captains as the strongest
the goti 13 ever was
now each of the 13 squads are led by a
captain captains are usually the most
respected soul reapers in the soul
society as the true power of the soul
society lies with them each of the
captains are master swordsmen and
experts in kido and shinbo they possess
immense strength durability and
endurance as well as having very high
tactical and strategic intellect
a captain has mastered the release
states of their zompark toe all of this
combined has earned them the authority
and respect of the soul society and
there are three different ways that a
soul reaper can become a captain of a
division one way is the captain
proficiency test which requires the
candidate to be able to perform bankai
this test is extreme and is witnessed by
the head captain as well as three other
captains
another way would be through the
personal recommendation of at least six
of the captains as well as the approval
from at least three of the remaining
seven
the final way a soul reaper can become a
captain is in trial by combat to do this
they would need to defeat a captain in
combat with at least 200 witnesses from
that captain's division present this
method is looked down upon due to its
barbaric nature but it is the only way
to become a captain without possessing
bonkai
now the 11th division actually has this
as the only method in which a soul
reaper can become a captain of their
division
so with that breakdown on the captains
there let's look into every captain's
zompoktow powers past and present
starting of course with division one
shun sui kyoko is the captain of the
first division and the head captain and
was the former captain of the eighth
division his zompoctor is called carton
kyokatsu which is translated to mean
flower heaven bone of madness in its
sealed form his sambacto is unique in
the fact that it is a daisho which is a
japanese term for a matched pair of
swords shoon suis consists of a tachi
and a wakazashi cartoon kyokatsu's
personality is unlike other zan park toe
as its personality comes to light in
battle and will only let shoon sweet
fight at his full power when it is in
the mood for it its shiikai command is
when the flower wind rages the flower
god roars when the wind of heaven rages
the god of the underworld sneers
in its shiikai form carton kyokatsu
becomes a pair of giant black curved
swords the wakazashi sword is used for
speed while the tachi is used for power
strikes the power of cutting kyokatsu
shikai form is to make children's games
real the zompocto itself makes and sets
the rules of these games and those who
step within its spiritual pressure are
forced to play and obey by these rules
which also include shun sui himself now
these games are essentially you win you
live and if you lose yeah you possibly
die pretty brutal stuff so let's look at
the games that we have seen so far
lazy spinning top is a technique that
represents the spinning top game where
large wind blades are fired towards his
opponent coming together to form a
tornado
mountain demon was seen in shunsui's
battle against stark shinsui explained
that the winner of this game was whoever
was higher than the other
shadow demon was a game where whoever
gets their shadow stepped on loses
however this game allowed its players to
manipulate their own shadows making it
harder for their opponent to step on it
lustrous demon was a colour based game
in which you say what colour you want to
cut with your sword and it won't be able
to cut anything else that isn't that
said color now if the color that you
call out is a color that doesn't appear
on your own body the damage will be
minimal even if the attack would have
been a fatal one prior to this game but
it works in both ways that if the color
does exist on your own body then the
damage dealt is equivalent to how much
of that color you have on your own body
so to deal out maximum strength it would
be advantageous to call out your skin
colour or the colour of your clothing if
you were wearing black robes as an
example basically the gist of the game
is risk in order to deal greater damage
to your enemy you must also increase the
risk to yourself as well
the next game we saw was the dharma doll
fell down this is based on the
children's game red light green light
where either schoonsweet or his opponent
are marked as being it the other can
travel towards the one who is it on a
trail of their spiritual energy however
they have to catch them by surprise
because if the one who is it sees their
opponent while they are moving the
opponent loses the game
the final game is shadow sending which
is based on the children's game chi chan
where children would stare at their
shadow on the ground for a few seconds
before looking at another surface which
will produce an after image of their
shadow how the game plays out is that
shoon sui or his opponent can project an
after image after staring hard at their
shadow and then project the after image
in a different location now the higher
the opponent's spiritual energy the more
realistic the after image will appear to
be
shunswee's bankai is katun kyokatsu
karamatsu shinju when he releases his
bonkai and aura covers the area around
shunswe and this aura changes the
perception of a person's surrounding
environment who is caught within its
range everything becomes dark and gloomy
causing them to feel despair and sadness
now shoon sweet's bonkai and its aura
change playing out the acts or dawns of
a play shunswee's bonkai actually
changes the battlefield itself to suit
his needs the first act is hesitance and
apportionment of wounds where any wounds
that either shun sweet or his opponent
inflict on the other's body will also
occur on their own as well shunswee says
this is the story of a man who suffers
from the same wounds as his partner
however he cannot die from them the
second act is called the pillow of shame
which makes black spots appear all over
his opponent's body causing them to
bleed heavily the story continues here
where shunswe says that this is the man
of the story feeling shame after
wounding his partner which caused him to
collapse and become very ill
the third act is the severing abyss
where a huge amount of water engulfs
both shoon sweet and his opponent this
water remains on the battlefield until
either he or his opponent run out of
spiritual energy and drowns
of course continuing shoon sui's story
he says this is the part where the two
characters both hurl themselves into the
rushing waters
the final act thread cutting scissors
upon a blood streaked throat is where
shoon sweet sheathes both of his swords
and wraps a white thread around his
opponent's throat before pulling it
tight enough to leave a deep cut blowing
up the head
yeah
this act completes his story where he
says that the regretful man's partner
ignores his pleas and without mercy cuts
their throat
gen ryusai yamamoto was the former
captain of the first division and the
head captain of the 13 court guard
squads
his zambok toe is ryojin jakka which is
translated to mean flowing blade young
flame riojin jakka is the oldest and
most powerful fire type zompok toe its
strength is so overwhelming that it has
greater attacking power than all of the
other zampak toe in the soul society in
its sealed form it is usually concealed
within a wooden staff that yamamoto has
used as a spear now if he were to peel
back the wood it reveals the true form
of his zampak toe which is that of a
standard katana its shiikai command is
all things in the universe turn to ashes
and in its shiikai form the blade is
completely engulfed in fire the weapon's
aura simply incinerates everything that
it is swung out leaving nothing behind
but ash the heat that comes from the
flames of ryujin zhaka in its shiikai
form are hot enough to scorch the sky
itself
now ryoshi and jakka has some pretty
amazing abilities when it's in its
shiikai form which include fortress
blaze where a huge wall of flame is
erected surrounding its target before
becoming a sphere which traps the enemy
within torch is a technique where
yamamoto can create a giant inferno with
a simple wave of his zompoc toe the
flames from this inferno engulf and
consume its target until only ash
remains these flames can also be
controlled by yamamoto himself to only
attack the target that he so chooses not
only that but he can also control how
intense these flames are too
flames of hell is the last technique but
equally as insane as the others where
seven or more pillars of flame are
created these pillars are to trap his
opponent within their inferno and
destroy them completely the power of
this ability is so intense that anyone
trapped within its boundary including
yamamoto himself will be incinerated
yamamoto's bankai is called azanka
notachi when yamamoto activates his
bankai the blade takes the form of an
old worn-out katana that looks to have
been scorched by fire any flames that
had previously been produced by riojin
jakka are instantly absorbed into the
blade and will burn anything it cuts out
of existence completely yamamoto's
bonkei is split into four abilities
being zankanotachi east west south and
north
zanka no touchy east rising sun edge is
automatically activated upon the
bangkai's release and its ability
focuses all of the intense flames to the
very tip of the sword these flames do
not burn the enemy but instead
incinerate them into complete
nothingness
zanka notachi west remnant sun prison
garb again is activated automatically
upon the release of his bankai
yamamoto's body is completely engulfed
in heat which reaches temperatures of 15
million degrees as you would expect it
is impossible to touch him or even get
close to him while his bankai is
activated this ability is insane as the
heat from this is that high that it
doesn't take on the appearance of flames
in fact they are completely invisible to
the eyes of his opponent unless yamamoto
himself wishes for them to see it zanka
no tachi south great burial ranks of the
10 trillion fire dead calls upon and
summons the corpses of the ones who were
killed by his flames to fight for him
now yamamoto impales the ground with his
sword and using the heat from it on
their ashes the dead appear like burning
skeletons from the very cracks in the
ground that he had just made who will
attack his enemies till they return to
dust yamamoto can also call forth
specific corpses if he so wishes
finally there is zanka no touchy north
heaven and earth ending ashes which is a
very powerful slash of heat and flames
that just incinerates everything that it
touches completely out of existence now
due to the extreme heat that radiates
from both the blade and yamamoto himself
there is a time limit on which he can
use his bankai he can only wield zanka
notachi for a short amount of time
otherwise prolonged use of his bankai
will destroy his opponent the area
around him or even yamamoto himself
soy phone is the captain of the second
division as well as the
commander-in-chief of the stealth force
as the commander of the stealth force
soy phone is a master in the art of
assassination she is skilled at
remaining hidden and striking down a
target completely undetected in an
instant
she has a very advanced technique at her
disposal called shunko or instant war
cry where she combines her expert
hand-to-hand combat and keto soy foam
will completely surround both her arms
and her back with pressurized keto soy
phone wears a uniform that has no
sleeves and no back because the pressure
from this technique would rip those
sleeves and the back part of her uniform
straight off when activated now the
technique itself takes on the form of
wind that she can direct towards her
target in a blast not only that but she
can use this wind to bolster up her
defenses on specific parts of her body
when she used this in her fight against
yurichi it was incomplete but mastered
the technique fully shortly after which
is called infinite shunko previously the
wind would only form and concentrate
around her right arm but once mastered
would revolve in a vortex around her
entire body being able to maintain the
technique for as long as she wanted
moving on to her zampacto zoyphones is
suzumabachi translated as meaning hornet
in its sealed form it is like that of a
wakazashi
she enters suzumabachi's shikai release
by using the command sting all enemies
to death now the sword shrinks in size
and takes on the form of a black and
gold gauntlet on her right hand it has a
small chain and a blade that looks like
a hornet stinger needle under her middle
finger the needle is around two of soy
phones fingers in length and though the
blade has become a smaller needle it
still has enough behind it to block the
incoming attacks from her opponents
so her shikai's special ability is
called double strike finisher and it has
two steps to it the first is to stab her
enemy with the needle which will leave a
butterfly shaped mark where she struck
her opponent this mark is called the b
crest flower and is now the target area
for the second step or attack of this
ability so if soy phone can strike her
opponent a second time in that exact
same spot it will ultimately result in
their death and is known as the death in
two steps so a much larger b crest
flower appears in its place which will
destroy her target's body this ability
is actually that of a venom that spreads
throughout the target's body in mere
minutes however the more spiritual
pressure the target has the longer the
venom will take to spread so these
crests are maintained by soy phones will
and are impossible to remove unless soy
phones so wills it soyvon has said that
she can only maintain these crests for
half an hour which was always more than
enough time for her to land that second
strike
soy phone's bonkai is called jacoho
rycobun translated as hornet thunder
duke whip her bankai takes the form of a
giant golden missile its base completely
engulfs her right arm all the way above
her shoulder that forms a face shield
covering that right side of her face the
missile itself is absolutely huge in
fact it's twice the size of soy phone
herself who stands at 4 foot 11 meaning
that this golden missile is
approximately nine foot 10 inches so soy
phone's bonkei is a ranged type and she
has the ability to launch the missile at
her target she raises her right arm and
uses the slit in the face guard to line
up her shot once the target is locked on
the missile tracks said target with
precision and on contact the missile
creates an incredible explosion of
course there are downsides to her bonkai
and the fact that she has stated that
she can only fire one missile every
three days anything more than that is
extremely taxing on her body
soy phone actually uses her bankai so
rarely the reason being is you know of
course how taxing it is to use and the
fact that soy phone prefers not to use
it as it damages her pride as the
commander of the stealth force
yorichi is the former captain of the
second division and the former
commander-in-chief of the stealth force
as the former commander of the still
force yurichi is a master of
assassination and is a very exceptional
fighter she is of course most famous for
her flash step and holds the title of
flash goddess or flash master she can
move great distances in the blink of an
eye making it impossible for her
opponent to keep up she has mastered the
flash step to the point where it appears
as if she is in multiple places at once
wiping out entire squads in the matter
of seconds now the insane thing about
yurichi's flashstep is that to this day
the full extent of her ability is still
unknown just as soy phone yurichi also
has the advanced shunko technique or in
her case it's called flash war cry but
instead of the element of wind your
ichi's is lightning now it works pretty
much the same as soy phones where she
has to wear a uniform that has no
sleeves and reveals her back and when
activated a white lightning surrounds
urichi her arms and legs are enhanced
and she can shut down her opponent's
movements she can also fire the
pressurized keto as blasts at her target
creating large explosions urichi's
version of the technique was mastered
over a century ago and because of that
she has mastered a couple of its forms
the first is flash warcry thunder god
battle form where the lightning from her
back takes on the form of raijin's drums
behind her that yoricci will unleash a
huge column of electrical energy at her
target engulfing them completely the
second is flash war cry thunder beast
battle form flash god black cat warrior
princess with the previous form already
activated yo richie transforms further a
huge electrical column is released and
when the electric gets dispersed yurichi
has an electric cap form where her feet
become clawed feline paws with electric
covering her forearm and legs electric
also flows through her hair to form
electric cat ears as well as gaining an
electric cat tail in a nutshell she
turns into an electric cat in both mind
and body her mood drops more than usual
and she becomes pretty unstable which is
very very bad news for her opponent and
of course sticking with the feline theme
an ability that is unique to yorichi is
her feline transformation she can
shapeshift into a small black cat that
has the ability to talk now there
doesn't seem to be a time limit to this
transformation as she had been in her
cat form for over 100 years and of
course though she is a small black cat
she can still move at incredible speeds
and this form is a complete disguise
even her voice is completely different
as it sounds like that of a deep male
now she was a former captain and as such
has a zompot toe her style of combat was
exclusively a combination of
hand-to-hand combat and her flash step
so she rarely ever used her zomboto we
do know that she achieved bonkai and
sheikai but they have never been
revealed to us
rojiro otarobashi more commonly referred
to as simply rose is the captain of the
third division and was previously a
captain 100 years prior to his exile his
zampakto is called kinshara which is
translated to mean golden sharla in its
sealed form it takes on the appearance
of a katana he has an ability called
arpeggio where he levitates his zompoc
toe sheathed within its scabbard in
front of him horizontally he then begins
to move his fingers over the zampacto as
if he were playing the piano which is
also accompanied by the sound of said
notes being played when rose does this
his hand glows a golden colour as a wire
appears that wraps around his target the
notes that he plays will then constrict
the wire crushing the target trapped
within
now to release his zompocto into its
shiikai form his command is simply play
his zompokto then takes on the form of a
long golden whip with a flower at its
tip that will impale his target the whip
is similar to that of renji's chicai
where it can extend and retract making
it an obvious ranged weapon while in use
the whip makes the light sound of a
piano playing it has an ability called
golden saltry sonata number 11 16 day
old moon rose where the flower at the
tip of the whip will attach itself to
his opponent rose taps the whip and
instead of a piano playing it is now the
sound of guitar strings the sound
vibrations travel through the whip and
creates a vortex of sound that will
create a blast when it reaches the
flower that is attached to his target at
the end
his bankai is kinshara butterdan which
is translated to mean golden sharla
dan's trope when his bonkai is activated
a giant pair of golden floating hands
appear one is holding a conducting baton
and several large golden looking beings
appear that are known as the dancers of
death rose's bonkai is like that of a
play using music he can create physical
illusions with rose himself stating that
the music gives him power over his
target's heart as long as their heart is
deceived and the way that his bonkai
works is by manipulating his opponent's
sense of sound tricking them into
believing that physical pain is being
endured the attacks that rose can
perform are like that of a play where
the dancers of death follow axe act one
is sea drift where the dances of death
surround his opponent and spin around
creating a whirlpool of water this makes
the target feel as if they are drowning
the second act is prometheus rose
conducts the dancers to generate fire
with their hands and the effect of this
illusion makes his target feel as if
they were of course burning alive the
final act which again i will probably
pronounce wrong is called ein heldenben
yes which is german for a hero's life
this unfortunately was never seen
because he was taken out before he got a
chance to use it
now of course rose is advised and as
such has the ability of holification
where when his mask is activated it
greatly increases his shinigami powers
his mask resembles that of a medieval
doctor's plague mask
gene ichimaru was the former captain of
the third division until he betrayed the
soul society along with both eisen and
tozen
gein has a genius level intellect and
was hailed as a child genius in his
youth destined for very great things he
even got a seated position pretty much
straight after graduation from the
shinigami academy now geen uses his
intellect to deceive and manipulate his
opponent he remains extremely calm
whilst he toys with his confused enemy
he plays with them to the point where
their mind is completely weakened and
their resolve diminished it is then that
he will deliver a fatal strike now his
son pogto is called shinso which means
sacred spear when translated in its
sealed form it looks like that of an
ordinary wakazashi his shiikai is
activated using the command shoot to
kill and its special ability is that it
extends at a very high speed impaling
his enemy with ferocious force as well
as that he will swing his zampacto
around while it is extended to destroy
wide areas or take out multiple targets
all at once
his shiikai can extend up to 100 times
its original length which earned it the
title of hundred swords now geen's
bonkai is called kamishi no yari
translated to mean god killing spear in
its banchai form his zompot toe doesn't
really change an appearance the ability
of his bankai is also the same as his
sheikah in which the blade glows a
bright white colour and extends at very
high speeds and force of course when his
bankai is activated the force speed and
length of his blade are all vastly
improved okay in terms of numbers gene
claimed that his sword could extend to
8.1 miles at 500 times the speed of
sound meaning his sword would be able to
extend 171000
500 meters in under 0.8 seconds however
this was later revealed to be allied
just to gain the advantage in battle
using his manipulative style of combat
the deadliest ability of his bankai is
that while it is expanding for a split
second the blade itself turns to dust
there is a deadly poison within the
blade that can dissolve and break down
cells gene will leave a tiny part of his
zompoc toe inside the body of his
opponent when he retracts his blade
which allows him to kill his target at
any time as he wishes to do this gene
will place his hand on the target and
utter the technique's name of korisei
kamikshini no yari causing the person to
break down from the inside out
next up is shusuke amagai who was from
an anime only arc amagai was another
former captain of the third division
succeeding that of guinea ichimaru his
zampakto is called rika which means
lightning flash which in its sealed form
resembles that of a kadachi his
sheikai's release command was sever and
the appearance of his zompak toe changes
to a long white blade with a hook at the
end and shell-like pipes at its hilt the
pipes emit powerful flames that produce
the sound of a trumpet now the special
ability all revolve around those pipes
that emit the fire armor guy can heat up
the blade which causes it to become much
more intense
in doing so armagai can shoot fireballs
from the hook of his zampok toe
launching them forward with the swing of
his sword he can also slam his zambocto
into the ground with a fireball
concentrated at the tip to send flames
straight towards his target his bankai
was called riker goenkaku which when
translated means lightning flash karmic
flame shell when activated his zompog
toe took the appearance of a large and
more detailed version of its shikai it
becomes a large crimson red sword with
jagged edges and a hook at the end it
also had a large white shell covering
the hill and the sword became as tall as
amaga himself
so when his bonkai is activated fire
surrounds the sword and he can use a
host of abilities that involve said
element including using it as a
flamethrower it can shoot enhanced
fireballs armor guy can generate fire
from the ground when he pierces it with
his unpacked toe crate waves of fire and
so on now he also has the ability going
ryuga where amigai will twist and spin
the sword above his head the blade is
completely engulfed in fire and flames
will shoot out of it he will then slam
the zompoc toe into the ground along
with a lightning strike as the ground
itself begins to shake fire spears will
also shoot from the ground at various
angles trapping his enemy within
now omega also had his bakoto which was
shaped like a tuning fork and had its
own unique abilities
he could fire green energy blasts from
it he could also tap his bokoto against
the hilt of his zampakto which will
create a large green blade of energy and
by stabbing this green blade into the
ground further energy will engulf amagai
which allowed him to communicate with
others within a certain area now his
pagoto has a true form the bakoto will
feed on the nuclei of odbokoto and
amigai's nucleus was an eye hidden
beneath its hilt when released the
nuclei extends and extends upon amagai's
right arm turning into the black
gauntlet that was like a claw in his
hand a sash appears on his left shoulder
that contains five pocoto nuclei within
it and attached to both the sash and
armored right arm is a dragon-like tail
from his back its special ability is
that the energy blade is like a dragon's
mouth that will sound out a pulse that
will completely negate a soul reaper's
power the way that it works is that the
resonating sound will cut the connection
between the soul reaper and their
spiritual energy rendering their zompoc
toe completely useless however amigai's
connection to his zampakto is left
completely unaffected
retsu unohana was the former captain of
the fourth division she was one of the
oldest captains amongst the soul society
and was their best healer she was also
the first person to hold the name
kampachi so uhana began practicing
healing techniques as a way of being
able to prolong her battles but through
her constant research and her medical
and healing knowledge she became the
greatest in the soul society she is a
master of medical intellect when it
comes to healing and herbal healing
techniques and has a very vast knowledge
of autonomy meaning that she can heal
more than shinigami as she has treated
both humans and aranka
so her zombocto was called minazuki and
her bankai was of the same name though
their translations were different so her
zompog toe when translated means flesh
drops gorge in its sealed form it
resembles an adachi and is a slightly
longer than an ordinary katana the
release command for her shikai is
unknown but in its released form
minizuki takes on the form of a green
giant one-eyed creature that looks like
a manta ray this creature is used for
transportation where it can either fly
or grow legs for transportation on land
hashikai's special ability is healing
those that are placed within the
creature's mouth the person placed
inside will then be swallowed and stored
within the creature's stomach where the
acids will cover the wounded individual
the creature's stomach acids are like
that of a strong medicine or ointment
now the creature itself can carry up to
six people in its stomach at one time
and once the healing process is
completed or i guess at unhanas command
the creature will regurgitate the people
out of its mouth now like i mentioned
earlier her bankai was of the same name
as her zompak toe minozuki though of
course i said the translations were
different her banchai when translated
means all things end
when her bonkai is released the blade of
her zompoc toe turns into a thick dark
red liquid that flows all around her
which many have theorized is blood but
there is no confirmation of that the
liquid of her bonkai is that of a very
strong acid strong enough to melt an
opponent to the very bone now
unfortunately there isn't a lot known
about her bonkai as she was killed
before we could really see what it was
capable of but we do know that it was a
very very nasty one
shinji hiroko is the captain of the
fifth division he was also a captain a
hundred years ago prior to his exile
shinji was also the leader and recruiter
of the visas
his zampogto is called sakanade which
means counter-stroke when translated in
its sealed form it looks like that of a
normal katana now hishikai release
command is collapse when in this form
his zompokto becomes a very large ring
that allows shinji to rotate sakunade
around his hand without grabbing the
zompok toe at all the spinning is the
shikai's ability the ability is called
upside down world as the zompocto is
spun a pink mist is created this mist
has a very pleasant aroma to it but if
smelt the target will fall into an
optical illusion this illusion affects
his opponent's eyesight and sense of
direction even the injuries they have
sustained aren't in the location that
they think they are everything is thrown
off and will cause all sorts of effects
including nausea vertigo and confusion
and no matter how strong the opponent
they all fall victim to sucking nades
illusions and are unable to adapt to
them now we do know that shinji had
achieved bonkai however it hadn't been
revealed to us
what we do know is he of course has
hollification the holification enhances
his strength speed and endurance as well
as that he is also capable of using a
cerro blast shinji's mask resembles that
of a
pharaohs sosuke eisen is the former
captain of the fifth division before he
betrayed the soul society along with his
followers gene and tozen okay so where
to start with eisen this man truly has
it all he is a master of combat and keto
use with a spiritual power that is
completely unmeasurable he is incredibly
strong and has a masterful level of
spiritual power control and it's not
just strength and battle prowess that he
masters but intellect too eisen is a
genius his intellect unmatched when it
comes to strategy technique history and
more he has conducted countless
experiments for over a hundred years
that involve things such as holification
but of course he also uses his genius
for manipulation eisen is extremely
cunning and has betrayed so many that
have fallen into the trap of trusting
him some have always kept an eye on him
but he has always alluded them
so in terms of his zompocto and his
abilities his zombocto is called kyoku
soigetsu which is translated to mean
mirror flower water moon in its sealed
state it of course looks like that of a
normal katana his shikai release command
is shatter which will activate and
deactivate it the special ability of
kyoko soy getsu is complete hypnosis it
will control all five senses of his
target that they misconceive a person's
form feel and smell to be that of their
enemies to fall under its hypnosis the
target must initially see kyoko soy
getsu upon its release and by seeing it
just once they will fall under its
control every time that it is released
even if they haven't seen it in a very
very long time the power of kyoko soy
getsu's hypnosis is so strong that even
if a person knows they are under its
control they will still fall victim to
its effects
this ability is truly devastating and
one that really matches eisen so well
it's incredibly useful to him both in
and out of combat now not only can he
make his target think that other people
are their enemies but he can use it so
it affects their view on himself to
create decoys so he can hide his true
movements and strike at the right
opportunity now when it comes to his
bonkai eisen's obviously strong enough
to have achieved it but it has never
been revealed now the only thing to
mention when it comes to eisen's power
is when he fused with the hokyoku eisen
himself underwent a few different
transformations that went far beyond
that of a soul reaper and hollows his
zompak toe was disintegrated when his
body fused with the hokyoku but eisen
was still able to use his illusionary
powers
eisen also gained a somewhat immortality
when his body fused with the hokyoku all
his wounds were instantly regenerated
now of course he eventually reverted
back to his normal state after each
gokurasaki's mugetsu in their battle the
hokyoku rejected eisen but he retained
both his immortality and his amazing
spiritual power by the time of the
quincy blood war eisen eventually
surpassed the power of the forms he had
when fused with the hogiaku
biakya kuchiki is the captain of the
sixth division and the 28th head of the
kuchiki clan who are one of the four
great noble clans within the seoul
society byakuya was taught flashstep by
yorichi but has never beat her biakua is
most well known for this technique and
is one of the best users of this within
all of the soul society he has a very
devastating ability and also his
favorite to use which is called senka or
flash blossom when translated he moves
at his opponent's back directly
attacking and sealing their saketsu and
hakusuy in two very rapid and
devastating strikes which cuts off their
spiritual energy flow now his zombocto
is called zenbon zakura which means
thousand cherry blossoms when translated
that looks like a simple katana in its
sealed form hishikai's release command
is scatter the special ability of his
shikai is that zembon zakura separates
into a thousand tiny fragments that are
incredibly sharp and look like cherry
blossom petals the tiny blades disperse
from the hill to his zampac toe and when
biakria swings his hilt the tiny blades
shred his opponents at his control
byakiya can also use them as a form of
defense as they are strong enough to
block incoming attacks from his enemies
now zembonzakura also has a safe zone
that protects biakya from his own
attacks where they will not cut anything
with
centimeters of him himself however if he
so wishes the blades can enter that safe
zone
biaku's bankai is called zembon zakura
kageyoshi which when translated means
vibrant display of a thousand cherry
blossoms his bankai is a larger version
of his shikai where instead of being
able to create one thousand flower
petals in its shiikai form zenbon zakura
kageyoshi can create millions biakio
drops his zompak toe which then goes
into the ground through a puddle of
water and energy ripples throughout
turning the surrounding area dark now
two rows of giant swords rise from the
ground and no one knows just how many
swords have risen these blades unlike
hishikai can be controlled using his
mind and further enhanced if he uses his
hands to direct their motion now he has
the ability senki or slautoscope which
is the true form of zembon zakura the
scattered petals form into thousands of
glowing swords that circle around
beyokia and his opponent in rose moving
in a circular motion this actually turns
his thousands of blades into fewer but
they are more powerful swords that each
have stronger attack power
biakyo can control these swords mentally
but often prefers to wield them
physically though this is the true form
of zenbone zakara this ability is one
that is extremely rare for even him to
use
bjorkya will only ever use this ability
if he has personally swore to take down
his opponent with his own two hands now
this ability also requires bjorki's own
blood to activate which could be another
reason as to why he doesn't use it that
much
now sticking with this ability it has a
sub ability within it called ika
senjinkar where he will attack a single
target with every one of his senki
swords at once this is sembon zakurakage
yoshi's ultimate attack another of his
abilities is called gokai which is a
sphere of tiny petal blades which will
swirl around his opponent and then trap
them in this cloud
not one angle is left uncovered by these
petals meaning that there is not only no
blind spots but there is also no escape
the sphere then collapses within itself
destroying the target trapped within the
last ability is called shuke hockett
taikan this ability takes all of the
thousand petal blades and compresses
them into one giant sword which boosts
its power the blade takes on the
appearance of a bright white bird and a
halo circle appears at biatria's back
made of spiritual energy and then the
strike is a final finishing blow
ginray kuchki was the former captain of
the 6th division and the 27th head of
the kuchiki clan over 100 years ago
until he was eventually succeeded by his
grandson biakya interestingly his
lieutenant when he was the sixth
division captain was his son sojung
kuchki
now we know that ginray was incredibly
strong due to the fact that he was a
captain but not a lot is known about him
his zompokto shikai and bongkai have not
been revealed to us but we do know that
he had achieved all of its releases we
were also told that his zompakto's
sealed state looked very much like
biakia's zembon zakura in appearance
sajin komamura was the former captain of
the seventh division his son pakto was
called tenken which means heavenly
retribution when translated and looked
like a normal katana in its sealed state
his shikai release command was raw and
his zompok toe kept the same form as
when it was in its sealed state now his
shikai's special ability was that tenken
would create various phantom body parts
of the armored giant that would copy the
exact movements of komamura these body
parts would all have a much enhanced
strength to them that would completely
overwhelm his enemy not as strong as
when the body was complete in bankai of
course but they still packed a very
impressive punch now his bankai was
called kokujo tengen myo which when
translated means divine retribution
black ropes of ruination when his bonkai
is activated the full giant samurai is
summoned which was referenced to as a
bankai of living armor the giant itself
stands around a hundred meters tall and
it wields a blade similar to that of
komamura's just like hishikai his giant
copies his exact movements with its
strength far greater than that of his
shikhai allowing him to deal an insane
amount of damage to his opponent
the giant can also take a hit itself and
despite its overwhelming size it is
still incredibly fast as it copies
exactly what komomora is doing if he was
to heal himself the giant would also
heal as well meaning that this is the
only bangkai that can heal itself then
there is kokujo tengen myo dangai jo in
this form the giant completely sheds its
armor exposing its body that is made
entirely of spiritual power this form
can only come to be if komamura uses the
humanization technique and when in this
form his bankai is pretty much
invincible to any physical damage
speaking of the humanization technique
this is a very special technique unique
to those from the werewolf clan this
allows them to completely shed their war
form and return to their human form this
is achieved through ritual a ritual that
is only achieved by removing that
person's heart the body becomes a shell
and by offering their heart said body
becomes immortal meaning that while in
this state attacks will have no effect
on both komamura or his bankai as the
wounds are regenerated instantly
rabu aikawa simply referred to as love
is advisored and the former captain of
the seventh division his zampokto is
called tengumaru which means long-nosed
goblin when translated it has the
appearance of an average katana while in
its sealed form his shikai release
command is crushed down and the
appearance of tengumaru goes from the
katana to that of a very large black
kanabo that looks like cactus
tengumaru in its shiikai form is also
more than twice the height of love who
stands at six foot two meaning that his
senpak toe is over 12 foot its special
ability is that it can manipulate fire
and has an ability called fire blowing
gavel where love will swing his zompoc
toe and it will ignite itself in flames
as he points his zompoc toe down a
fireball is released from its tip that
will explode as soon as it makes contact
with its target
now as advisored he of course has
hollification which significantly boosts
the strength speed and endurance of his
shiny gummy abilities he also has an
ability called mirror opening which is a
technique of brute raw strength love was
able to rip a menos grande clean in half
with his bare hands using this ability
in terms of his mask his holo mask takes
the form of a traditional japanese oni
mask
lisa yaromaru is the captain of the
eighth division one of the most unique
things about lisa is that she is
ambidextrous meaning that she can swap
hands effortlessly during combat while
wielding her zompot toe she has a
technique called thousand page wholesale
where she will utilize her ability to
use both hands delivering multiple sword
movements that happen so fast resulting
in her target being shred to pieces
her zombocto is called haguro tombo
which is translated to mean iron
dragonfly in its sealed state it is a
lot longer than most resembling that of
a nadachi her shikai's release command
is smash which turns the appearance of
her toe from a sword to a long pole with
a blade fixed at its tip similar to that
of a monk spade on the other end of the
pole is a large heavy ball the heavy
ball at the end allows her to use her
zomboc toe like an axe hershey kai's
special ability is unknown but we have
seen her use a move called 21st article
dragonfly landing where lisa dished out
multiple piercing attacks all at once
against her opponent lisa's bonkai is
also currently unknown and has not been
revealed to us just yet she does have
holification being advised giving her
that boost in strength and endurance but
hasn't shown any ability that is
specific to her holification in terms of
her mask it is a lozenge shape and has a
cross opening instead of mouth and eye
slits
kensei muguruma is the captain of the
ninth division he again was a captain
over 100 years ago prior to his exile
and again is also advised muguruma is a
guy that despite being a master
swordsman with his zampakto prefers
fighting using hand-to-hand combat he's
a beast with extreme strength his
zampakto is called tochikaze which is
translated as meaning earth-severing
wind and in its sealed form looks like a
wakazashi kensei's shiikai release
command is blast away its shiikai form
turns his zampakto into a combat knife
its special ability comes in the
manipulation of both wind and energy
where its slashes turn to explosions
we have zinnim used two abilities using
his shikai which include air blades
where kensei will release multiple
slashes from a distance that will cut
the enemy down before exploding causing
a huge amount of damage the other
ability is called bomb thrust where
kensei charges up tachikaze with spirit
power till it takes the form of a
glowing ball of light this he will then
fire his enemy in a devastating and very
powerful blast
kensei's bankai is called tekken
tachikaze which is translated to mean
iron fist earth severing wind when his
bankai is activated a large explosion of
wind engulfs him after its dispersed
tachikaze is transformed from a combat
knife to a pair of large knuckle blades
with purple bandages wrapping around
both of his arms like a sort of armor
there is also a thicker purple band that
wraps around over his head now his
bankai's ability focuses all of his
shikai's power into the two knuckle
blades giving kensei's punches insane
destructive force that he will
continuously pummel his opponent with as
long as that knuckle blade is in contact
with his opponent a barrage of
explosions will continuously go off
as well as his destructive power kensei
can also change the knuckle blades into
brass knuckles as well as spiked
gauntlets and of course as a visor he
has holification powers too that greatly
enhance his strength and speed his mask
resembles that of a hockey face guard
kaname tozen was the former captain of
the ninth division before he betrayed
the soul society alongside eisen and
ichi maru his zompocto is called
suzumushi which means bell bug when
translated in its sealed form it looks
like a regular katana
now when it comes to his shikai tozens
is not like a regular zanpok towing the
fact that it has two shiikai commands
both with unique abilities the first is
when he uses the release command hal his
zombokto keeps the same katana form of
its sealed state but a high pitched
noise occurs over a large area those
that hear this high pitched noise will
be knocked unconscious
the other shikai ability is called
cricket second movement crimson flying
lotus this ability turns suzumushi into
its benihiko form suzumushi begins to
vibrate and as tozen begins to move his
sword in a circular motion a trail
appears following the sword's movement
this trail then turns into hundreds of
blades that are then fired straight at
his opponent
tozen's bonkai is called suzumushi
suishiki enma kurogi which is translated
to mean bell bug closing ceremony field
cricket when kaname activates his bankai
the ring on his katana begins to spin as
it spins it starts to release spiritual
energy the ring begins to spin faster as
it grows in size and then splits into 10
separate glowing rings of equal size
that will circle around kaname himself
with the slash of his sword the rings
disperse and create a large circular
perimeter and the 10 rings begin to form
a black void that will continue to grow
in size until it forms a large solid
black dome within the dome a vacuum is
created that completely nullifies the
senses of sight sound scent and
spiritual energy the only sense that
remains is that of touch allowing kaname
to attack them with his sealed zompot
toe now the dome itself is an extension
of susan mushi which allows kaname to
wield the sealed zompot to itself within
said dome
the weakness to his bonkai is that by
touching suzumushi's hilt you become
immune to the dome's effects so if his
opponent manages to touch the hill his
bankai becomes pretty useless now the
dome will continue to exist as long as
kaname wishes or if he becomes seriously
injured
so tozen also has the power of
holification that enhanced his powers
strength speed and endurance as well as
that he also had high speed regeneration
while wearing his mask talking of his
mask kaname's hollow mask covered the
majority of his head and neck there was
a gap at the back for his hair and he
had a line that went through the middle
of the mask horizontally which split the
mask into separate parts
finally kaname had his resurrection
called suzumushi hiyakushiki gorilla
grilo which is translated as bell bug
hundreds ceremony crazed cricket in this
form tozen's body took the form of a
giant bug covered in black fur with four
insect arms two giant horns and wings
this form enhanced his strength as well
as all of his sound abilities not only
that but he also maintained his high
speed regeneration
he had two abilities in this form with
the first being lost nouveau spektas aka
the nine aspects using his claws tozen
drew green circles in the air that would
emit a huge burst of sound a sound
strong enough that would crush
everything around it the second ability
is la mirada or the greys where tozen
charges up a huge green cero from both
of his eyes the two form together before
he fires it at his target
toshiro hitsugaya is the captain of the
10th division hisagaya was the most
gifted prodigy in the soul society since
that of gin ijimaru often referred to as
a child genius gene had called him the
embodiment of the heavenly white angel
that blesses the soul society once a
century not only is he the guy extremely
impressive physically his intellect is
equally as impressive his zombocto is
called hyorin maru which is translated
as meaning ice ring in its sealed state
it looks like a normal katana however
his zombocto is around 1.4 meters in
length which is longer than your average
zompot toe because heats again is pretty
small standing at four foot four he has
to wear it sheathed on his back because
it is too long for him to wear around
his waist
now he's the guy can use the abilities
of his zambocto without water being
present and this is because hyorin moro
is the strongest isompakto in all of the
soul society in fact his guy's control
over his zambok toe is so great that he
can actually use some of his bonkai
abilities while hiron moro is still only
in its shiikai form however they can
backfire and harm him too his shikai's
release command is reign over the
frosted heavens in its released form
hyorin moro becomes slightly longer in
length and also gains the addition of a
crescent blade on its hilt attached by a
metal chain which can also extend and be
used to attack his target his shikai's
special ability is that it allows his
guy to control the elements of water and
ice the slashes he perform are not only
enhanced in power but also create a form
of ice that takes the shape of a chinese
dragon that will freeze anything that it
touches
the difference between its shiikai and
bangkai abilities are pretty small but
the abilities of hishikai are as follows
the first is subjugation of the heavens
which is both his most basic ability but
also his strongest where he can control
and manipulate the water and in the
atmosphere around him then he has
multi-layer vacuum ice wall which
creates a wall made of multiple layers
of ice because this is a multi-leveled
ice wall it can even withstand some fire
attacks which of course is the element
that he is weakest against
he can also use this offensively in a
technique called vacuum ice blade where
he will manipulate all of the ice that
he has gathered and focuses it at the
tip of his zompoc toe before firing it
straight at his opponent there is also
another ice wall technique called woven
ice wall where he will erect a wall of
ice by weaving fine threads of ice
together
his final shikai ability is called six
clothed ice binding array where hezagaya
will place five snowflake shaped pieces
of ice on the ground creating a trap for
his opponent once they step on this trap
each of the snowflakes send a line of
ice straight at them that will encase
that target in a giant pillar of ice
he's a guy as bangkai is called daigoran
hyorin maru which is translated to mean
grand crimson lotus ice ring
when heat segaya activates his bonkai
his form changes where ice from hyorin
moro begins to flow into hezagaya on his
right hand the ice forms into a dragon's
head and his sword becomes encased in
ice the ice continues to form two wings
on his back and a long tail the ice
continues down his left arm where an ice
claw engulfs his hand heatser guy's feet
are also encased in this eye similar to
the claw on his left hand all of these
frozen limbs are fully functional and
can be used as an extension of himself
during battle
three purple flowers of ice also
sometimes appear floating behind him
each of them have four petals these
petals melt away as the battle
progresses i guess you could say these
petals are a somewhat timer of how long
heatser gaia can remain in his bankai
form
now he's the guy can freeze both objects
and his surroundings just as his shiikai
form however when his bonkai is
activated this is much stronger and the
range is greater in terms of techniques
hisagai has zanyo ningyo lingering ice
puppet where he can create a large
amount of ice that is shaped to look
exactly like him these ice replicas are
very lifelike enough so that they even
bleed
heatser guy can also use his wings as a
shield where they will wrap around him
like a sphere to protect him from
attacks he also has bankai regeneration
where his bankai will regenerate as long
as there is water in the air
ryusenka is an attack where he will stab
his opponent and a burst of ice will
appear encasing his opponent heats a guy
will then shatter the ice with his
target trapped within he also has senen
hyoyo thousand years ice prison heat
sagaya will create loads of ice pillars
which circle around both himself and his
opponent when he commands it these
pillars will begin to move towards his
enemy crushing them
gun show serrara icicle flock is where
his sagaya will freeze water into ice
and by swinging his zampak toe in an
arc-like motion daggers of ice will
propel towards his target
hyorio sembi ice dragon swirling tail is
a swinging motion from hitsugai's
zampocto that creates an ice blade that
shoots towards his enemy he also has
zeku or void sever which allows heza guy
to control this technique further even
sending the ice blade into the air
heatser guy's most powerful technique is
called hyoton kyokasu frozen heaven
hundred flower funeral this is an
ability that is an extension of his
subjugation of the heavens power where
he can manipulate the water in the
atmosphere be it rain snow and ice at
will with kyoto kyokasu a huge hole
opens in the clouds and snow starts to
fall when the snowflakes make contact
with his opponent they create ice
flowers that appear all over their body
that will instantly trap them in a huge
pillar of ice
after the battle with eisenhisagaya
strengthened his bankai through 18
months of training into its completed
form he himself claimed that his body
wasn't mature enough at the time to
completely control his bonkai and use it
to its fullest potential but after
reaching a more adult-like body he has
achieved this
ishin kurasaki was the former captain of
the 10th division ishin is an absolute
powerhouse as you would expect from the
head of the kurasaki clan one of the
best ways of showcasing his strength
other than his many epic fights with
ichigo of course is his only deco pin
technique where ishin can send an
opponent flying with incredible force
with just the simple flick of a finger
his zambocto is called engetsu which
means scathing moon when translated in
its sealed state it looks like an
ordinary tachi ishin shikai release
command is burn and the appearance of
zompocto does not change however it is
engulfed in a fire-like spirit energy
esheen can use an energy attack when he
is wounded where he will use his own
blood and spit it onto the sword which
will then release an insane amount of
spirit energy that he will then use to
pummel his opponent
now the epic ability ashing can perform
is his own getsuga tensho which was
incredibly powerful he used this against
eisen in the fake karakura town not only
did it completely demolish the
surrounding buildings but it also left
eisen with a large gash in his head
earning a compliment from him eisen said
that the attack was splendid and it was
an attack that ishin fully understood
now ishin does have bonkai but it has
never been revealed to us it was said
that if sheen tried to use it the bonkai
would put a large amount of strain on
his body a strain so large that it would
leave him heavily injured
kenpachi zaraki is the current captain
of the infamous 11th division and is
also the 11th kenpachi to hold the
position and when it comes to
powerhouses and choosing a guy you do
not want to meet on the battlefield it's
kenpachi's iraqi he is incredibly tuned
to combat his swordsmanship is brutal as
is his expert battle senses
words that are choosing to describe his
power are words such as supernatural and
immeasurable which really gives us an
understanding of just how much of a
fearsome presence he really is
and his spirit energy is absolutely off
the charts so much so that he has to
wear an eye patch over his right eye
kenpachi admitted that he has poor
control over his spirit power and he has
to rely on said eye patch to keep it at
a manageable level once that eye patch
is removed his spirit energy goes wild
completely destroying large areas that
can span miles away the energy is just
so heavy and overwhelming that his
opponent is almost always frozen to the
spot when it is released it is released
in energy and shock waves but also
serves as additional armor only those on
the same level or higher than kenpachi
can cut through his spiritual pressure
and land a cut on him
now his zompak toe is called nozarashi
which means weather beaten when
translated as a child without training
kenpachi was able to imprint onto his
zampogto in terms of his appearance it
is much longer than a regular zombocto
its hilt is covered in bandages and it
is extremely jagged on the blade those
in the soul society believed that it was
kim pach's insane spiritual pressure
that was forcing his zampakto into a
release state due to this unique design
and interestingly kampachi was the only
captain in the history of the 13 court
guard squads to achieve the rank of
captain without both knowing the name of
his zompoc toe or being able to perform
either of its release stays he of course
gained the rank of captain through the
exclusive and looked down upon trial by
combat it wasn't until he was beaten by
ichigo that he wanted to get stronger
where he gained the name of his zombocto
and achieved its release states
kenpachi's shikai release command is
drink his zompokto's appearance changes
to form a giant axe-like weapon with a
long grip its special ability in its
release form is an insane power-up in
nozarushi's strength and cutting power
its power is enough to completely
destroy a meteorite with just a single
blow kampachi can cut clean through his
opponents with ease even being able to
cut through space itself
now the name of ken parche's bankai is
currently unknown but we do know what it
does so when activated a huge level of
energy is released an energy so powerful
that it will take out buildings in the
surrounding area kempachi himself
changes his skin turns red and gains
black markings over his face as well as
gaining the addition of horns his zompoc
toe also undergoes a change looking like
an alternate version of its shiikai
state
this is the only bonkai we know of that
actually changes the world and not only
physically but mentally too
in this form kenpachi is like that of a
demon berserker who gains an incredible
amount of strength and power he acts in
a pure fit of rage where he is consumed
mindless and acts without regarding his
own life
mayuri kurotsuchi is the captain of the
12th division and is also the second
president of the shinigami research
institute he was formerly the third seat
of the 12th division under kisuke
urahara mayori is in my mind a crazy
almost evil genius he has the most
intellect and scientific mind within the
whole society he has performed many an
invention and researched body
modification but has also experimented
on himself and upgraded his own body
parts to use in combat and in
conjunction with his zompot toe in some
cases before a battle he will thoroughly
study his opponent and make
modifications to his own body just to
give himself the advantage
looking into his body modifications he
has flesh splash which is like an escape
tool where he will stab himself with his
sealed state zanpac toe turning himself
into a green liquid that can neither
attack or be attacked he can still move
around and speak in this form and will
return to his normal state in a few days
he also has snake belly arm where his
left arm can extend to that of a
grappling hook if this arm were to be
attacked it will explode on impact but
this isn't a problem for mayuri as he
has a regeneration serum that will
replace the lost limb
mayuri is also able to pull out a part
of his ear to form a scythe that is
still attached to him like a flesh-like
rope that he will use to cut down his
opponent
he has a camouflage technique called
false skin where his body can blend in
with the colors and textures of his
surroundings now majori's craziest
modification has to be that he can
replace any of his lost organs with fake
ones that are just as functional as the
originals but are a lot less vulnerable
even crazier is that this operation will
take less than an hour to perform
so moving on to his zompoc toe it's
called ashisogi jizo which is translated
as the leg cutting guardian its
appearance in its sealed form is like a
normal katana with the guard covered in
a cloth with spikes sticking out just
below the blade during the quincy blood
war mayuri modded his zompoc toe by
adding a sensor that blocked all sword
attacks within two feet of his body at
an angle of 60 degrees or greater his
shikai's release command is rip the form
changes to that of a golden trident with
curved blades the guard of the zompok
toe is shaped like a baby's head with
its hands in prayer
mayuri shikai's special ability is that
of venom when his opponent is stabbed by
ashisho the signals from the brain that
control movement are severed leaving
them paralyzed the only thing not
affected by the venom is the nerve
endings and pain receptors meaning that
his opponent will still be able to feel
all the pain the paralyzed limb endures
he also has a shiikai ability called leg
cutting jizo terror magnitude 4 where
myori sticks his finger in one eye of
the baby's head on his zambok toe
causing a dark fluid to come out of the
baby's mouth anyone who does not share
the same blood as mayuri that hears this
sound will be completely paralyzed for
four seconds
mayuri's bankai is called kanji ashish
jizo which is translated as divine leg
cutting jizo when his bonkai is
activated a giant monster looking
creature appears that has the body of a
caterpillar and a huge creepy baby head
wearing a red cape with baby arms and a
halo hovering above his head this
creature breathes a poisoned copy of
mayuri's blood that is deadly to anyone
who breathes it in aside from myori
himself or nemu this poison can spread
through an area of around 200 meters and
is almost impossible to evade now there
is an antidote to this poison but it is
obviously kept by both himself and nemu
now just as mayor had modified his own
body he has also modified his bankai too
making one of the most versatile he has
rigged his bankai to self-destruct and
return to its sealed state if it were to
attack him his bonkai also has
retractable blades that shoot out from
his chest that will completely skewer
his enemies this can also be combined
with its poison for an even more
deadlier effect further modifications on
his bonkai led to kanji ashishi jizo
matai fukiyan shotai which is translated
to simply demonic recumbent womb this
form is that of a giant purple skinned
baby wearing a golden loin cloth it has
a giant gash on its stomach with the
kanji for conceal written on it and is
also resting on a large pile of
umbilical cords now this creature can
create modified versions of kanjiki
ashishi jizo that have the information
or data that mayori had sent to it that
copies the abilities of the one that
have attacked it
kisuke urahara was the former captain of
the 12th division and was also the
founder and first president of the
shinigami research and development
institute kisuke is for me just a really
hyped character he just has it all
amazing strength insane spiritual power
genius intellect and big big moments
now his zombocto is called benihime
which is translated as crimson princess
this is actually one of the very few
female zompocto spirits known and
urohara himself has described his blade
as not nice in its sealed state it is a
beige-colored shikomizuay which is a
blade hidden within a cane when urahara
was still a captain his zombocto's
sealed form was that of an average
katana
now hishikai's release command is awaken
and the blade takes the form of a
medium-sized sword that has a decorative
hill and a crimson tassel hanging from
it his shiikai's special ability is a
vary of techniques that manipulate a
crimson energy and through verbal
commands from kisuke benehime will
execute said technique
the first is sing crimson princess
scream which are blasts of ferocious and
destructive crimson energy that are
fired in the shape of an ark these
blasts are strong enough to take on in a
spider class iranka's cerro blood miss
shield is where a hexacan shaped crimson
barrier forms a defensive perimeter
blocking incoming attacks
razer crimson princess is a technique
very similar to sing crimson princess
scream where it again fires an arc of
crimson energy straight towards his
target cutting them with ease
spurning crimson princess is a technique
that will cancel out an enemy's attack
upon contact all kisuke has to do is
analyze the opponent's technique where
we're talking spiritual energy
composition and muscle movements once
that is done a circle of crimson energy
is drawn that will cancel out said
attack
crimson princess of binding is a
blood-red net made of condensed energy
being thrown over the target from the
tip of benehime's blade using a slashing
motion
the final ability is called fire playing
crimson princess beaded mesh which is
performed after using the previous blood
red net technique kisuke will stab the
net with the tip of benejime's blade
that will create balls of fire all over
the outside of the net that will explode
like mines devastating the one trapped
within the net
now kiskey's bonkai is called canon
biraki benehime
which is translated to mean open red
princess neo when activated urohara's
bankai takes on the form of a giant
woman with dark braided hair with
mannequin-esque arms wearing a red robe
that stands behind him urohara keeps the
sealed sword for use in combat his
bankai has the ability to completely
restructure anything that it touches
offensively this can be used to split or
dissect something and for support it can
enhance things to bring them to their
optimal working state and beyond urahara
reconstructed his arm to have even
greater strength against askins
completely overwhelm him it can even
stitch things back together that were
once broken we saw urohara restore his
own eyes using this power to restore his
vision against again askin this is just
how insane the true power of his
bonkai's reconstructing ability is
ruki akuchi is the current captain of
the 13th division where she was formally
served as the lieutenant under jushuru
ukitake
ruki's greatest strength is arguably her
mastery and knowledge of kido where she
can use it to attack bind and even heal
she stated that while she was at the
shinigami academy that she was the
highest in her class when it came to the
use of keto however when she joined the
13th division her use and knowledge of
keto was average in comparison to the
other squad members so she trained
extremely hard to develop her skills her
zomboctomy is called soda no shirayuki
which means sleeves of white snow when
translated in its sealed form it looks
just like that of a regular katana
hershey kai release command is dance and
soda no shiraiyuki is described as the
most beautiful zampato in all of the
soul society
when it is in its released form the
blade still looks like that of a katana
but a very elegant one it also has a
long white ribbon from the hilt that
forms a perfect circle when rukia holds
the blade upside down
now sodno shiraiyuki is an ice type
zompok toe and its shiikai form has
multiple techniques that it can perform
that are all labeled as dances
the zompocto's standard chikai ability
is that it freezes it can freeze targets
from a distance or create paths of ice
in mid air interestingly it's not her
chica that freezes objects from the
blade but that it actually drops the
temperature of what it touches to below
freezing basically anything that rukia
touches will be affected her sanbok toe
only extends her reach
so the abilities or dances available to
her shikai form are as follows sono mai
sukishiro or first dance moon white is a
technique where rukia holds the glowing
blade upside down making a slashing
motion when the enemy is in position at
that moment she draws a circle with the
tip of her zambock toe anything within
that circle is frozen not only the
ground but the air too
everything within that circle's
perimeter is frozen into a pillar of
light the pillar will smash completely
with the target trapped inside now to
note if the target is not trapped within
that pillar said pillar will not shatter
sugi no mai hakuren or next dance white
ripple is a circle of eyes similar to
the previous ability that will form
where rookie stabs the ground she will
stab the ground four times in a
semi-circle and ice particles come up
from those punctures rukia then takes up
a stance and the particles flow to the
tip of her zampac toe that she will then
release in a very powerful cold blast of
air freezing everything that comes into
contact with it
sano mai shira fune or third dance white
sword is the ability where rukia gathers
all of the moisture in the air to the
tip of her zambok toe forming a blade of
complete ice this not only increases the
reach of her blade but also freezes
everything that makes contact with the
blade
juhaju or tree white is a direction of
ice that forms a trail towards her
target when she strikes the ground that
will continue to freeze until the target
is turned into eyes
now rukia also has something called ice
rope connection where she can create an
ice extension that will connect her hand
to the hiltifer zampocto if she is out
of its reach allowing her to use her
shikai abilities at a distance
her bankai is called haka notagame which
is translated to mean white haze
punishment when activated her banchai
changes her look and attire completely
this could also arguably be the most
beautiful bankai in the soul society
rukia is wearing a beautiful white
kimono with lined patterns it has an
extended collar with wider sleeves as
well as long flowing ribbons to finish
off that really majestic look rukia
herself has a small ice flower on the
center of her chest and a half crown her
hair also goes from a jet black colour
to a brilliant white and her zompot toe
becomes transparent just as ice
now ruki can turn the temperature within
her area of influence to absolute zero a
pillar of absolute cold mist rises way
up into the air and anything that is
close to her becomes frozen to the very
core the target becomes frozen and
begins to crumble away in seconds anyone
who makes contact with rukia while her
bankai is activated begins to freeze
instantly
jiushiro ukitake is the former captain
of the 13th division and the final
captain on our list his zampakto is
called sokyo nokotawari which is
translated as lore of the twin fish in
its sealed state his zompokto looks like
a regular katana
his shiikai release command is all waves
rise and become my shield lightning
strike now and become my blade
once his shikai is released his single
katana becomes two blades that he dual
wields as the two blades separate a
large red rope with five silver charms
appear that attaches to the hilts of
both swords
his shikai's special ability is being
able to absorb his opponent's energy
through the left sword that will then
travel through the red rope and its five
silver charms that each increase its
energy's attack speed and power reaching
the right sword where ukitake will fire
it straight back at his opponent with
much more devastating force this process
happens so fast that it is pretty much
unable to dodge
now ukitaki's bankai has not been
revealed to us but being a captain we
know he definitely had this ability
and that is it every captain's power and
ability from bleach explained this was
certainly one of the longer videos on
the channel so if you've made it this
far then a huge thank you from us here
at anime opera you truly are a legend
that stands tall among the masses
definitely make sure to let us know you
made it to the end of the video by
dropping a comment in the section below
letting us know who your favorite
captain is now if you enjoyed this video
and you'd like to see more bleach videos
on the channel make sure to let us know
by smashing that like button get sugar
10 show style if you haven't already
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future anime oprah videos remember you
can also follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime opera thanks again
and we can't wait to see you in the next
video till next time peace